I have a game for you guys tonight we're
gonna play a movie version of would you
rather we play this a lot of Collider
for tonight all horror theme first one
would you rather be in the front of the
group or the back of the group when
going through driving these back so I
can watch a laugh shove to the front but
I kind of rather bit back I don't like
being in the back then no one can
protect you but I'm usually the shield
so I'm always in the front oh I use my
end of honestly though yeah you would
I'm a lot like Taylor I'll end up
bouncing to the front and then we're
reading it because I don't get to watch
the hilarity ensues behind me you gotta
get to the front though because then the
person in front of you gets the full
effect of the scare and it's spoiled for
you if you're behind them that's true
clearly it's true we know where I fall
in this but it's totally worth it to be
in the back if you have like a party
member like Amy seen what stress hands
when I get pressed or scared if there's
a lot of this that happened there are a
lot of this is definitely a rewatchable
movie would you rather have a filmmaker
surprise scare you while shooting a
scene or getting the scare mode yourself
surprised here surprised scare and that
definitely happened in this movie oh
they were surprised scared spread scares
are fun I would say surprise scares yeah
I guess I know it cuz we we did have to
do both and the surprise scare takes I
was like that's all good but I also
think it would depend on the movie like
for this one surprise cares work but if
it's something that's like if there's
some like I don't know I don't know I
totally like brooding sociopath then I
would want to get any mascara but
because it's more jump scares that's way
more fun to have a surprise onset that's
what I tried to just like wait worse
I'm here to help them would you rather
face off against Michael Myers or Freddy
Krueger Michael Myers Krueger just cuz I
want to see him in real life I'd be like
it's really you what are we gonna do yes
so many rooms right you seem pretty
screwed in both scenarios - pretty
screwed Freddy is creative but I feel
like Freddy I'm more spur yeah no Freddy
would be much more painful yeah let's
see Freddy would also be in your
nightmares anyone talk to me so like if
I really want them I know what he's
gonna have if I really want like the
real experience of alright this is when
I die then Freddy if I want to have any
sort of chance of escape okay yeah he's
gonna slow walk it yeah he's just a
knife yeah how much other stuff and then
you can cuz he's everywhere that's right
true alright I have to say this one with
that laughing oh yay would you rather be
chased by a giant person with a little
knife or a tiny person with a giant
chainsaw
Chucky stuff right there doing tiny how
how well can this tiny person hold this
giant chainsaw this is a mystery you're
taking the risk right here alright I'm
gonna say tiny person in the hopes that
he just can't pick up the chainsaw he's
like come stand next to this chainsaw
rest of the button you got to walk you
got can you pull this thing for me he
ran in point you have to walk into it
something really scary thank you for any
higher villainy update I'm good at
persuading you to kill yourself that
happens I would take that because it
wouldn't be as scary I think anybody
who's super tall is a little bit
intimidating yeah honestly that's just
scary you're like whoa please don't beat
me up and he's like I'm not
okay worse than 12 hours I'm saying this
but size doesn't matter it's how you
wield it no [ __ ] would you rather be so
terrified by horror movies that you
could never ever sleep or never be
scared of a horror movie ever again ever
be scared of the horror movie I like
sleep too much I need sleep no no I mean
okay then I'll go with the other one
I'll take one for the team